Well,
the only country
that has used nuclear weapons against another country
was the United States,
that dropped 2 nuclear bombs in Japan
without military need,
in addition to having dropped those nuclear bombs.
Truma explained
and the Germans themselves have recognized this.
The Japanese are the country of the World,
after Taiwan,
who has the most admiration for Americans.
How do you know if they were to write them the constitution?
He has them,
they love them,
love them.
They consider the American model to be a good one,
eh?
Both hirohitor and MacArthur and Truman,
who are the big 3 actors at that moment.
They say,
it's true,
hirohitor says.
If we get to survive
the 200,000 would not have died
who died from nuclear bombs,
2 million would have died,
including 200,000 Americans,
because they did not surrender.
We had given orders and balloons
to defend themselves with a white weapon
when the explosives and firearms ran out.
So what are you waiting for?
Continue 2 more years of penetrating with troops
2 nuclear bombs eh?
Hey,
the nuclear bombs,
Pablo?
It is evident that they are the ones who have kept the Peace.
70 years so far 80.
No nuclear bombs
Peace would not have been maintained
because we have never had 1 period
in world history.
Is it possible from these?
But no,
it's not possible.
The fucking truth.
It may be yes,
but the truth
is that the only ones who have used nuclear weapons
against another country
is the United States.
Sure,
and that's 1 monstrosity.
Objectively well.
And okay,
for 1 monstrosity is objectively great.
And that, huh?
It's 1 fact,
Huh?
Completed and spilled water.
What do we do with the spilled water?